this is Grandmaster Daniel narditski we
are watching two Titans of the game
Magnus Carlson Hikaru Nakamura facing
off at the 2014 World Blitz championship
and Magnus essaying the scotch defense
the scotch opening which is not
necessarily the most common at the
highest level is showing the Rue Lopez
and the Italian in favor of a slightly
more rare line and Hikaru responding
with a bishop C5 variation which is uh
one of the most reputable along with
Knight F6 and both sides developing
their pieces Magnus developing the
bishop out to G5 pinning the Knight on
F6 and Hikaru looks up in a little bit
of consternation trying to remember his
analysis as he fiddles with the pawn and
Hikaru taking the first significant
think of the game as he tries to decide
how to deal with that Bishop on G5 and
he decides not to deal with it for the
time being as he continues to develop
and he castles King's side of the big
question for Magnus is which way is he
going to Castle he can move his Queen up
to D2 and he can Castle queenside or he
can develop his light squared bishop and
castle kingside and he does develop his
Queen he puts it on F3 pressuring
hikaru's Knight on E5 and Knight D4 is
nakamura's aggressive response staking a
claim in the center and offering a trade
of knights in the event of that trade
Hikaru lands a very powerful Bishop on
D4 which is going to be threatening in
some cases to take the Knight on C3 and
if the queen recaptures on C3 there are
tactics with Knight F6 takes E4 even
though the queen on d8 is hanging the
queen on C3 potentially will also hang
so Magnus has that problem to deal with
as now he falls behind by 30 seconds
Hikaru has played very confidently in
the opening and Magnus now taking a
piece of his own to fidget with as he
gives the position a sizable think and
there's the answer he castles Queen side
and once again Hikaru looks off to the
side maybe he's still in his analysis
will he take the Knight on C3 that's the
big question and if he does how is
Magnus Carlson going to recapture with
the queen or with the pawn if he has to
recapture with a pawn then his entire
Queen side is going to be significantly
damaged and Hikaru will have attacking
chances and Hikaru very enticed by that
possibility Magnus not even thinking
about taking back with a queen because
of Knight takes E4 and he takes back
with a pawn and now the big threat is E4
E5 winning the Knight on F6 Hikaru must
deal with that immediately and he does
he moves The Rook out to E8 and Magnus
completing his development by bringing
his light squared Bishop out to C4 now
notice that the pawn on e4 is
Untouchable it cannot be captured with
the Rook because if Queen takes E4 and
the Queen on d8 is going to be captured
by White's Bishop so the pawn isn't the
problem for white the problem for white
as Magnus takes a sip of caffeinated
Coca-Cola they're giving himself some
energy to think about this complicated
position the problem for white is that
damaged Queen side he cannot let Black's
Queen get to A3 or The Rook to get to
the a file all of that is a very
dangerous possibility but for the time
being white has some very active
development but a big move there by
Magnus is he trades his dark Square
Bishop for the Knight on F6 and he
essentially forces an end game where
both sides now have very damaged Pawn
structures black has that damage on the
king side and white respectively has the
damage structure on the Queen's head
Hikaru taking active steps to fix his
structure as he pushes the pawn up to F5
and he contests magnus's control of the
center the idea is to undouble his pawns
and in the event of a train on F5 black
gets his light squared Bishop out and in
that situation I think black is the one
who can argue that he's slightly better
so Magnus has to tread very carefully
here as he falls now to a minute 20 on
the clock he's a full 40 seconds down
and we know how dangerous Hikaru is in
his opponent's time pressure and Magnus
says no I'm not trading unless it's on
my terms and he drives the bishop up to
D5 he is provoking the move C6 which
looks very tempting but then the bishop
will drop back to B3 and hikara will
have problems with his Pawn on D6 so I
don't think he's automatically going to
play C6 another sip for a Magnus he
seems pretty happy with the way that the
end game is going in a big decision here
to be made by Hikaru and he finally
takes on e4 Magnus recaptures with his
bishop and rookie five by Hikaru
preparing to lift The Rook up to the
queen side but also putting the Rook on
a defended Square the threat was Bishop
takes H7 check with a discovered attack
against that Rook but now that the Rook
is on a defended Square Hikaru doesn't
have to worry about that anymore and
Magnus for the second time moves his
Bishop up to D5 knifing into Black's
position a trade on E1 and King f8 by
Hikaru to prevent white truck from
infiltrating to E7 the end game looks
pretty balanced to me but there is still
plenty of Chess left to be played this
is not a dead draw this is very far from
a dead draw because there's a lot of
Pawn structure imbalance with both sides
having weaknesses on the respective
flanks C6 now played by Hikaru driving
the bishop away from the center and will
Hikaru play D5 not just yet he develops
his Bishop to F5 and and moves it back
to G6 in order to reinforce that weak
Pawn on F7 and Magnus says I'm not
letting you sleep peacefully on G6 H4
and Hikaru immediately responds with H5
the idea for Magnus was to play G4 and
then H5 himself that was not something
Hikaru could have allowed Magnus brings
up his King into the center and Hikaru
pushes his Rook down to d8 reinforcing
the pawn on D6 Bishop C4 by Magnus is he
preparing to offer a bishop trade yes he
is and now Hikaru is the one who says
I'm fine to trade but if you want to
take on G6 you're gonna have to help my
Pawn structure improve Bishop takes G6 F
takes G6 and Black's kingside Pawn
structure is fully rectified I don't
think Magnus is going to trade no he
does not instead he pushes the a pawn up
to A4 grabbing space on the queen side
and Hikaru does the same with B6 it does
look like black has the more comfortable
side of this end game but the likeliest
outcome is definitely still a drop both
of these players are legendary in the
end game and Magnus drops the bishop
back to E2 thank taking better of that
Bishop trade and deciding to keep the
Bishops on the board as he pushes the
pawn up to A5 what a bold move there and
if Hikaru takes on A5 the idea for white
is Rook to A4 when white not only
recovers the pawn on A5 but then puts
tremendous pressure on the A7 and C5
Pawn so I don't think Hikaru is going to
capture that pawn on A5 in fact I'm
confident that he won't so he keeps the
tension Rook to F6 offering a trade of
Rooks does Hikaru Nakamura and in the
event of that trade I don't know who
benefits for the time being Magnus
trades on P6 and he falls now to 30
seconds on the clock he's got to make a
decision fast but he basically has to
trade because if he moves The Rook away
from F4 he loses that critical Pawn on
F2 so he plays Bishop F3 and he agrees
to a trade of Rooks but once again for
the third time he does it on his own
terms and he puts pressure on that D5
pawn and if he can force Hikaru to push
that pawn up to D4 and that D4 Pawn is
going to be a pretty massive liability
for blacks so a big decision here to be
made for Hikaru he can play Rook D6 and
keeps the Rooks on the board and he does
just that I think he's influenced by the
fact that Magnus now with 15 seconds on
the clock and the more pieces on the
board the more complicated the position
Magnus making a waiting move dropping
the bishop back to G2 and keeping his
eyes on the D5 pawn and Hikaru does have
a hard time bringing the king in toward
the center that Rook on F4 is an
absolute beast that's keeping Black's
entire King side at Bay and Hikaru
hesitating a couple of times there Rook
to d8 Bishop F3 decides repeating moves
Magnus is obviously fine with a draw is
Hikaru final the draw as well no Magnus
is not fine with the draw what a bold
decision by the world champion he brings
the Rook up to A4 but he immediately
puts it back on F4 thinking better of
his bold decision because Hikaru he's
got all of his pawns well defended by
that Rook on D6 and now it's nakamura's
turn to play for a win as he pushes B5
and supports the pawn of the rook and
Bishop drops back to G2 Magnus harassing
Black's Queen side pawns with his bishop
and now the pawn on default 5 is
Untouchable because of Rook D6 what a
vicious Trap by Hikaru in his opponent's
time pressure Magnus now with 10 seconds
on the clock and hesitation there as he
moves the bishop back to F1 for the
umpteenth time Rook a two by Hikaru
attacking C2 and now a bishop trade and
who benefits from this bishop trade it's
hard to tell now white is threatening
Rook F4 up to F5 forking the pawns on D5
and H5 Hikaru has to prevent that and he
does by moving his King up to G6 and now
it's madness's turn to expand on the
king side G4 leading to some frustration
by Nakamura and The Rook is it gonna
move up to G5 checking the king and
forcing it back to E6 and now Magnus
with a passed Pawn on H4 is he going to
push that pass Pawn not just yet he
plays Rook G1 preventing black stroke
from traveling to the king side via A1
now Hikaru the one who looks a little
bit frustrated white wants to put that
Rook behind the pawn on H4 and the pawn
is going to rumble up the board up the
runway Rook A3 by Hikaru pinning the
pawn on C3 and Magnus brings the king
back to D2 Hikaru desperately generating
counter player Queen side fiddling and
twirling that pawn Rook up to G3 by
Magnus offering a rook trade who
benefits in the event of that Rook trip
I think it was white Now The Rook Gets
behind the pawn but Hikaru is in time to
stop the pawn with his King he is just
in time tempo for Tempo and now the pawn
on H6 is immobilized and I think the
game is very likely to fizzle out into a
draw Rook to A6 winning the pawn on H6
Magnus wins The Pawn on B4 and now the
sides only have two pawns left and
they're about to have one Pawn left King
to E2 rookie six check back and forth go
the Rooks Rook takes D5 Rook takes F2
this is a dead draw even though Black's
King is further away from White's Pawn
than White's King from black spawn
because Black's Rook is more than
capable of holding that pawn back in the
sides repeating moves looking at each
other and shaking hands what a amazing
battle between these two players if you
enjoyed this video make sure to click
the link in the playlist for more of
these videos thank you so much for
watching
foreign